Hey guys, here comes a brand new episode of SmartLess. We're dropping the ball because it's right around New Year's and I'm about to drop mine too. And here I come into a ball drop Bateman for SmartLess. Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes.
嘿，大家好，SmartLess 的全新一集来了。我们现在有点手忙脚乱，因为快到新年了，我也快要“掉链子”了。贝特曼，SmartLess 的“掉球”时刻到了。Smart。Yes。Smart。Yes。
Smart. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes.
Smart。Yes。Yes。Yes。Yes。Yes。Yes。Yes。
Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes. Look at you, Will. You're in London. London. Yeah.
Smart。Yes。Smart。Yes。看看你，威尔。你在伦敦。伦敦。是啊。
London. Oh, is that your, that's a good, do it again. London. Oh my God. Right? I need some more. Guys, I can really do it. Will used to have the funniest on your cell phone, well, years ago.
伦敦。哦，那是你的，那很好，再来一次。伦敦。天哪。对吧？我还需要更多。伙计们，我真的能做到。威尔以前在手机上有一个最搞笑的，嗯，几年前。
You had the song London Calling and every time as your ringtone and that, and every time it rang, you, so stupid, you would go, sorry guys, that's London Calling. London Calling. Sorry. Oh. Will's the funniest. He's super funny, you guys. Stupid dick.
你当时把《London Calling》那首歌设为铃声，每次铃声一响，你就，太蠢了，你会说，抱歉伙计们，那是《London Calling》。伦敦在呼唤。抱歉。哦。威尔是最搞笑的。他超级搞笑，伙计们。蠢货。
Oh, I'm showing. Are we, we got a shake going? You little protein shake? Yes. I have. You just come from a birthday party? What's going on? You having a shamrock shake?
哦，我在展示。我们，我们有奶昔吗？你那小蛋白奶昔？是的。我有。你刚从生日派对回来？怎么回事？你在喝三叶草奶昔吗？
It's a little early. I don't, it's not March yet. Wait. This is what's in here. A banana, coconut milk, an apple, a pear, ice and just a suggestion of vanilla extract. Just a sneeze of extract. Well, what time is it there in London? It is six, just after six PM.
现在还有点早。我不，还没到三月呢。等等。这里面是这些。香蕉、椰奶、苹果、梨、冰块，还有一点点香草精。就加了一点点提取物。嗯，伦敦现在几点了？现在是六点，刚过下午六点。
So you're exhausted. You're winding down. I am exhausted. Yeah. I'm winding down. I've had a long day of, of writing with Chappie. That's what you're doing over there. You went to London to write or to learn how to write.
所以你精疲力竭了。你在放松。我精疲力竭了。是的。我在放松。我和查皮写了一整天的东西。这就是你在那边做的事。你去伦敦是为了写作，还是为了学习如何写作。
Yeah. And that and maybe watching some cricket, the T20 cricket as well. Wait a second. I can't do, I can't, I've had to deal with you falling in love with English football. Yeah. And pretend to be excited for your new passion. Is it going to be cricket now too? And should we hold the space for rugby?
是的。还有那个，也许还会看些板球，T20板球赛。等等。我做不到，我得应付你爱上英式足球这件事。是的。还得假装对你的新爱好感到兴奋。现在又要变成板球了吗？我们是不是还得给橄榄球留个位置？
I don't know what to tell you. That's a lot. That's a lot of space. It is. It is a lot. I just have baseball. That's all I ask you guys to indulge me with. You know, speaking of baseball, I watched that just as an aside, I texted both of you
我不知道该怎么跟你说。那太多了。那占用了太多空间。确实。确实很多。我只有棒球。这就是我要求你们迁就我的全部。你知道，说到棒球，顺便提一下，我给你们俩发了短信
guys. I watched, I finished that Inburns documentary on Muhammad Ali. Muhammad Ali. Yeah. I know. I saw, I saw it. I can't wait to watch it. It was, it was really, really good.
伙计们。我看了，我刚看完肯·伯恩斯关于穆罕默德·阿里的纪录片。穆罕默德·阿里。是的。我知道。我看了，我看了。我迫不及待想看它。它真的，真的很好。
What a, you know, he was a boxer, not a baseball player. You started this with speaking of baseball, but because he made, because I remember you got into baseball, you said your passion for baseball deepened when you watched the documentary about baseball that Ken did. So I was just drawing a line there. You know, I'm just trying to connect some dots, you know, that's what we do here on smart list is we, I feel like we just connect dots wherever we can. And they're so far apart.
真是个，你知道，他是拳击手，不是棒球运动员。你开头提到了棒球，但因为他拍了，因为我记得你迷上了棒球，你说你对棒球的热情是在看了肯拍的棒球纪录片后加深的。所以我只是在那儿画了一条线。你知道，我只是想把一些点连起来，你知道，这就是我们在SmartLess做的事，我觉得我们只是尽可能地把点连起来。而且它们相隔太远了。
And connecting dots, I'm about to connect some dots between myself and our guests today. Our guest today is somebody that I've now worked with and I just figured out, I guess it's three times technically, not technically three times that we've worked together. He's an incredible director. He's an even better person. He's super interesting. I like him a lot personally, in addition to liking what he does as a director. And he, he's a, he came to directing, Jason, I think that you're really going to enjoy
说到连点，我正要把我和今天的嘉宾之间的点连起来。我们今天的嘉宾是我现在合作过的人，我刚才算了一下，我想严格来说是三次，不是严格意义上的三次合作。他是一位出色的导演。他是一个更好的人。他超级有趣。我个人非常喜欢他，除了喜欢他作为导演的作品之外。而且他，他是一个，他是半路出家做导演的，杰森，我想你真的会喜欢
this because as you become, you know, directing becomes a bigger and bigger part of your life. This is somebody that you can talk to about his own evolution as a director. He started as a DP, a cinematographer and directed some of the more memorable films in the last 50, 100 years. I almost want to say cult films, but these are, these are huge cultural films. He's the DP on, on films such as, well, I don't want to get into directing cause you'll know exactly who it is. So I'm going to say he, he was a cinematographer on Miller's Crossing on Raising Arizona.
这个，因为随着你，你知道，导演工作在你生活中占据越来越大的比重。这是你可以和他交流他作为导演的演变过程的人。他最初是摄影指导，电影摄影师，并执导了过去50到100年里一些最令人难忘的电影。我几乎想说邪典电影，但这些是，这些是巨大的文化电影。他是这些电影的摄影指导，嗯，我不想深入讨论导演，因为你会立刻知道他是谁。所以我只想说，他是《米勒的十字路口》和《抚养亚利桑那》的摄影师。
He started his first film with them was with Joel and Ethan Cohn was blood simple and then he directed incredible films. Shut up and let's hear him. It's my friend Barry Sonnenfeld. Oh wow. Hello. Hello Barry Sonnenfeld. Oh my God.
他与乔尔和伊桑·科恩合作的第一部电影是《血迷宫》，然后他执导了令人难以置信的电影。闭嘴，让我们听听他怎么说。他是我的朋友巴里·索南菲尔德。哦，哇。你好。你好，巴里·索南菲尔德。天哪。
Hey, I have a request right off the bat. Yeah. I want you to call me right now on my phone so you can hear my ringtone, which I think is even better than Will's. If you got a second. Sure. Somebody in America want to do that. You do it.
嘿，我有个请求，开门见山。是的。我希望你现在就用手机打给我，这样你就能听到我的铃声了，我觉得它比威尔的还要好。如果你有空的话。当然。美国有人想做这个吗？你来做。
I bet my T wants to do it. So my T can call me on 778. I'm going to wait. I'm going to do it right now. Wait. Okay. Unknown caller. You just answer the phone.
我敢打赌我的T想做。所以我的T可以打778那个号码给我。我要等一下。我现在就做。等等。好的。未知来电。你直接接电话。
Answer it right now. Answer the phone. Barry, where are you? Barry, answer the phone. Okay. Can you name who that is calling me? Barry, answer the phone. You just answer the phone.
现在就接。接电话。巴里，你在哪？巴里，接电话。好的。你能说出是谁在给我打电话吗？巴里，接电话。你直接接电话。
Answer it. Oh God. Who is that? Who is that? Who is that? I lived in Telluride, Colorado for decades. They have an annual film festival. I went to undergraduate school with your friend Ken Burns.
接吧。天哪。那是谁？那是谁？那是谁？我在科罗拉多州的特柳赖德住了几十年。他们每年都有电影节。我和你的朋友肯·伯恩斯是大学同学。
Ken was having lunch with Werner Herzog, one of the great voices on the planet. So I went up to Werner and I said, Werner, you're going to record my ringtone. And it took like 30 takes. He kept improvising. I said, no, just say Barry, answer the phone. And then he went on and on. He'd get into my mother. So anyway, this ringtone just frightens the hell out of anyone because it's so obnoxious.
肯当时正和沃纳·赫尔佐格一起吃午饭，他是这个星球上最伟大的声音之一。所以我走到沃纳面前说，沃纳，你要录我的铃声。录了大概30遍。他一直在即兴发挥。我说，不，只要说“巴里，接电话”。然后他就没完没了地说了下去。他甚至扯到了我母亲。总之，这个铃声让每个人都吓坏了，因为它太讨厌了。
I'm so proud of you. Do you leave it on ringer when you're shooting on set? You know, everyone's got to go to vibrate on that. You should leave that one on. It's worth interrupting. Believe me. I do. I do.
我真为你感到骄傲。你在片场拍摄时会开着铃声吗？你知道，每个人在那种情况下都得调成震动。你应该留着那个铃声。它值得被打断。相信我。我会的。我会的。
It's worth ruining takes just like Werner's voice up there. Oh my God. Well, I'm such an enormous fan of yours, Barry. I'm so, so thrilled that I get to ask you questions and hear you for an hour. Yeah. Thank you so much for joining us. Do you guys know each other? Jason and Sean, do you guys know Barry at all?
它值得毁掉拍摄，就像沃纳在那里的声音一样。天哪。好吧，我是你的超级粉丝，巴里。我非常，非常激动能有机会问你问题，并听你讲一个小时。是的。非常感谢你加入我们。你们认识吗？杰森和肖恩，你们认识巴里吗？
I've never met. We've never met. We've never had the pleasure of meeting. I'm such a big fan. And you know what? I just watched a Shmigadoon and it's so fantastic. What the hell is Shmigadoon? So hard throughout that whole thing.
我从没见过。我们从没见过。我们还没荣幸见过面。我是你的超级粉丝。你知道吗？我刚看了《欢迎来到施米加多》，太棒了。什么是《欢迎来到施米加多》？在整个过程中笑得好辛苦。
It was so fucking funny. Well, thank you. First of all, you should know I hate musical theater. I hate musicals. Yeah. No, it came through in the show. That's why we're friends, Barry. That's why we're friends.
它太他妈搞笑了。好吧，谢谢。首先，你应该知道我讨厌音乐剧。我讨厌音乐剧。是的。不，这在节目里表现出来了。这就是我们成为朋友的原因，巴里。这就是我们成为朋友的原因。
It's an eight part Apple series, a half hour each episode. And it's about Cecily Strong and Keegan-Michael Key are having problems with their relationship. They go on this hike together, end up in this magical kingdom, kind of based a little bit on Brigadoon called Shmigadoon, where everyone sings in musical theater. So there's Alan Cumming, Kristen Chenoweth, Marty Short. It's a great group, Aaron's Vite. So we had all these great musical theater people. And I hated musicals and I would go to the showrunner every day.
这是一个八集的苹果剧集，每集半小时。讲的是塞西莉·斯特朗和基根-迈克尔·凯在感情上出了问题。他们一起去徒步旅行，最终进入了一个神奇的王国，有点基于《布里加多恩》，叫《施米加多》，那里每个人都在唱音乐剧。所以有艾伦·卡明、克里斯汀·肯诺恩斯、马蒂·肖特。这是一个很棒的团队，亚伦·斯维特。所以我们有所有这些伟大的音乐剧演员。但我讨厌音乐剧，我每天都会去找剧集主管。
I directed them, but Cinco Paul wrote them and I'd say, do we really need this song? And he would get upset and then we would shoot it. But. That's so funny. Listener, I wish you could see this. Barry has taken his ring light and he's pulled it over. He's created a key side and a fill side. Yeah.
我执导了它们，但辛科·保罗写了剧本，我会说，我们真的需要这首歌吗？他会很不高兴，然后我们还是会拍。但是。太搞笑了。听众朋友，我希望你能看到这一幕。巴里拿起了他的环形灯，把它拉了过来。他创造了一个主光侧和一个补光侧。是的。
It's just, the man's just got visual taste. I just got to say, Jason, you didn't do that. Yeah. I did. No, I'm terribly top lit and it's hitting my big fat ball nose. There's a lot wrong. There's a really a lot wrong. It's just us.
这人就是有视觉品味。我不得不说，杰森，你没这么做。是的。我做了。不，我的头顶光太强了，正打在我又大又肥的球鼻子上。有很多不对劲的地方。真的有很多不对劲。只有我们。
I mean, Jason looks like he's doing, you know, when you've got to insert the shot of the security cam, he looks like he's got that going. I literally. There's no art. There's no art to what you're doing. I mean, this is, this, I built this set. It's beautiful. Wait, so Barry, Barry, let's start at the beginning if we can just for a second, because
我是说，杰森看起来像是在做，你知道，当你需要插入安保摄像头的镜头时，他看起来就是那种效果。我真的。没有艺术。你做的事情没有艺术感。我是说，这个，我搭建了这个布景。很漂亮。等等，所以巴里，巴里，如果我们能从头开始，哪怕一秒钟，因为
I want to get into, to your, you know, your beginnings in getting into film and, you know, we've talked about it before. I know you have a lot of, you've had an interesting path to say the least, which started with, you went to film school. You went to NYU, graduate film school, graduate film school, grew up in New York, NYU graduate film school. And then your, your first foray into filmmaking was in the pornographic world. Is that true?
我想深入了解你的，你知道，你进入电影行业的起点，而且，你知道，我们之前谈过。我知道你有很多，至少可以说你走过一条有趣的道路，始于，你上了电影学校。你去了纽约大学，研究生电影学校，研究生电影学校，在纽约长大，纽约大学研究生电影学校。然后你的，你第一次涉足电影制作是在色情世界。这是真的吗？
Right. That's not true. And you also, I write about in the book that we used a really bad light for our film light. You should use like a little snooted pinhole camera just to illuminate the insertion area. But we used a 750 watt soft light, which just flooded the thighs and it was just so wrong. So ugly. Wait, this is fast. I didn't know this about you.
对。那不是真的。而且我也在书中写到，我们为电影灯光用了一个非常糟糕的灯。你应该用一个小型的针孔摄像头来照亮插入区域。但我们用了一个750瓦的柔光灯，它只是泛滥了大腿，这太错了。太丑了。等等，这很快。我不知道你这事。
Okay. So you get out of film school and this is pre-video, you know, there were only 35 millimeter cameras in 16. So we were shooting. So I bought, when I got out of film school, I bought a U16 millimeter camera, a CP16 reflex thinking if I owned a camera, I could call myself a cameraman without being like the dilaton, right? And my buddy who I bought this used camera with got us a job shooting nine feature length
好的。所以你从电影学校毕业，那是视频出现之前，你知道，当时只有35毫米和16毫米摄像机。所以我们在拍摄。所以我买了，当我从电影学校毕业时，我买了一台二手16毫米摄像机，一台CP16反射式摄像机，心想如果我拥有一台摄像机，我就能称自己为摄影师，而不像个业余爱好者，对吧？然后我和我一起买这台二手摄像机的朋友给我们找了一份工作，拍摄九部长篇
porno's in nine days. And we blocked shot. That's funny. What's that moment? Like how do you, how do you make that move? And I know you're just paying your dues. How do you make your move from that? And then you start getting into the kinds of films that you want to do.
色情片，九天拍完。我们分段拍摄。那太搞笑了。那一刻是什么感觉？你怎么，你怎么做出那个转变的？我知道你只是在积累经验。你是怎么做出转变的？然后你开始进入你想做的电影类型。
Yeah, because it wasn't porno's. And by the way, if porno's were released with smell or vision, no one would ever watch a porno again. But so the same 16 millimeter camera, I am at a Christmas party where there's no one but wasps and one other Jew who looks a little bit like Howard Stern and it's Joel Cohen. We sort of smell each other. We approach each other and we start chatting. Well, Vimp Vendors, an American friend had just come out, which was a really great movie
是的，因为那不是色情片。顺便说一句，如果色情片是用“气味电影”发行的，就再也没人会看色情片了。但还是那台16毫米摄像机，我在一个圣诞派对上，那里除了盎格鲁-撒克逊白人新教徒和一个看起来有点像霍华德·斯特恩的犹太人之外，没有别人，那就是乔尔·科恩。我们互相闻了闻对方。我们走近对方，开始聊天。嗯，维姆·文德斯的《美国朋友》刚上映，那是一部非常棒的电影
and we were talking about it. And Joel was telling me that he and his brother Ethan had just written blood simple and they were going to shoot a trailer as if it were a finished movie and use that trailer to raise 750 grand to then go to Austin and shoot this feature. And I said to Joel, well, I own a camera and he said, you're hired. So I shot the trailer for blood simple. We loved working together. The trailer looked great.
我们在谈论它。乔尔告诉我，他和他的兄弟伊桑刚写了《血迷宫》，他们打算拍一个预告片，把它当作一部完成的电影，并用那个预告片筹集75万美元，然后去奥斯汀拍摄这部长片。我对乔尔说，嗯，我有一台摄像机，他说，你被录用了。所以我拍了《血迷宫》的预告片。我们喜欢一起工作。预告片看起来很棒。
We became friends. Joel, Ethan and I took a year. We raised 750 grand and the first day on the set of blood simple was the first day that Joel, Ethan or I had ever been on a feature film. Wow. Joel had never worked his way up, was never an AD or anything like that. Ethan was a statistical typist at Macy's. He had been a philosophy major at Princeton and didn't want to go back.
我们成了朋友。乔尔、伊桑和我花了一年时间。我们筹集了75万美元，在《血迷宫》片场的第一天，是乔尔、伊桑或我第一次在长片电影片场工作。哇。乔尔从未从底层做起，从未做过助理导演之类的。伊桑是梅西百货的统计打字员。他在普林斯顿主修哲学，不想回去。
And this is presaging things. He wrote a letter to Princeton as if he was his parents saying that Ethan was recently in a terrible chipper accident and lost his arms and legs and was too embarrassed to return to Princeton. So he literally dropped out without telling his parents. So we raised the money for blood simple and the first day on the set of that movie was the first day any of us had ever been on a movie set. Do you remember what the first scene was that you guys shot?
这预示着一些事情。他给普林斯顿写了一封信，假装是他父母，说伊桑最近发生了一起可怕的碎木机事故，失去了双臂和双腿，太尴尬了，无法回到普林斯顿。所以他真的在没告诉父母的情况下退学了。所以我们为《血迷宫》筹集了资金，那部电影片场的第一天是我们所有人第一次在电影片场。你还记得你们拍的第一场戏是什么吗？
Oh, wow. I can remember almost every scene of that movie. Oh, wow. That's a really good question. I was a terrible camera operator, just awful. Oh, so you were operating and D.P. Yeah, because we couldn't afford, you know, and this is pre any sort of video tap. So they never could see my framing and because that would have been good because they would
哦，哇。我几乎记得那部电影的每一场戏。哦，哇。那是个非常好的问题。我是一个糟糕的摄影师，简直太糟糕了。哦，所以你既是摄影师又是摄影指导。是的，因为我们负担不起，你知道，这是在任何视频辅助设备出现之前。所以他们永远看不到我的构图，因为那本来会很好，因为他们会
have said, Hey, you know, all the Dolly track is in that shot. Should you just tilt up? So, you know, with them not having any video assist and them being so known for their precision and the specificity of their composition, I'm sure you'll be you'll be delicate and political here. But tell us to the extent you're comfortable what the ratio was of you kind of informing their taste with that since they had to be obviously so trusting of you. They couldn't see anything until until daily's the next day.
说，嘿，你知道，所有的轨道都在那个镜头里。你应该向上倾斜吗？所以，你知道，由于他们没有任何视频辅助，而且他们以构图的精确性和特殊性而闻名，我相信你会在这里表现得谨慎和圆滑。但请在你能接受的范围内告诉我们，你以那种方式影响他们的品味的比率是多少，因为他们显然必须非常信任你。直到第二天看样片之前，他们什么都看不到。
Did you help them kind of learn what they're known for today? Well, it's funny when you say there was no video assist and how much was I involved? There's literally a scene and video assist, by the way, Tracy, is the ability for people other than the cameraman to see what the camera is seeing. It's a monitor. It's a tap. As you can see with the camera, which is now we take for granted anytime you shoot a film or a television program, the cameras are pointed at whatever they're shooting the scene.
你是否帮助他们了解了他们今天所闻名的东西？嗯，当你提到没有视频辅助以及我参与了多少时，这很有趣。顺便说一句，特蕾西，视频辅助是让摄影师以外的人看到摄像机正在看到的东西的能力。它是一个监视器。它是一个分流器。正如你所看到的摄像机，现在我们认为这是理所当然的，任何时候你拍摄电影或电视节目，摄像机都指向他们正在拍摄的场景。
And then everybody can watch on these monitors effectively watching on a TV what the what the camera is shooting. Before I answer that question, Jason, I've got some directing advice for you and maybe you do this already. I believe that you should direct only from the camera and not from video village. Old school just sitting on an apple box under the mat box under the mat box because then right away is first of all, the actors know you're there, you're present and you're the audience, you can immediately go in and say, no, talk faster, which is the only thing you
然后每个人都可以在这些监视器上观看，实际上是在电视上观看摄像机正在拍摄的内容。在回答那个问题之前，杰森，我有一些导演建议给你，也许你已经这么做了。我相信你应该只在摄像机旁执导，而不是在视频村。老派做法，就坐在遮光斗下的苹果箱上，因为那样的话，首先，演员知道你在那里，你在场，你是观众，你可以立即进去说，不，说快点，这是你唯一需要对演员说的话，威尔可以告诉你。
ever have to say to an actor and we'll can tell you that. Can I tell you, Barry has a, he's got a saddle that is kind of on wheels that he sits on instead of a chair and he can wheel. This is true and he wheels around the set and he's right next to the camera and then he can wheel over here and then he'll, he'll, they'll, they'll sort of keep rolling or cut and he'll wheel over to you and say faster. Sometimes he'll just say funnier, he'll say flatter, flatter, flatter, flatter, never funnier.
我能告诉你吗，巴里有一个带轮子的鞍座，他坐在上面而不是椅子上，他可以滑行。这是真的，他在片场滑来滑去，他就在摄像机旁边，然后他可以滑到这边，然后他会，他们会，他们会继续拍摄或喊停，他会滑到你身边说快点。有时他只会说更有趣，他会说更平淡，更平淡，更平淡，更平淡，永远不要更有趣。
You never want the actors to act funnier. You just want them to act real and if the scene is funny, then you'll be funny. But in any case, the other thing is, I think if you're at video village, you start to get lazy and you start to yell one more and you never need one more without changing something or you don't need one more. So anyway, back to the Cone Brothers answer, the truth is Joe Ethan and I spent six months designing every shot. We had floor plans, we had shot lists, we had storyboard, you know, little thump storyboards.
你永远不想让演员演得更有趣。你只想让他们演得真实，如果场景很有趣，那么你就会很有趣。但无论如何，另一件事是，我认为如果你在视频村，你就会开始变得懒惰，你就会开始大喊“再来一次”，而如果不改变任何东西，你永远不需要再来一次，或者你根本不需要再来一次。所以，回到科恩兄弟的回答，事实是乔尔、伊桑和我花了六个月时间设计每一个镜头。我们有平面图，我们有镜头清单，我们有故事板，你知道，小小的缩略图故事板。
So we taught each other how to do that stuff and we have a very similar style since I've become a director and they've used other cameraman. They're just not as good visually, but that's just because they've started to pan. I never let them pan. I think panning is the laziest thing you could ever do. Never pan, always track, but panning is just like, either let them leave frame and come back in or track with them. So I remember being at the premiere of a, what's that Scorsese movie with Daniel Day-Louis
所以我们互相教导如何做这些事情，自从我成为导演以来，我们有非常相似的风格，他们也用过其他摄影师。他们只是在视觉上没那么好，但这只是因为他们开始平移了。我从不让他们平移。我认为平移是你所能做的最懒惰的事情。永远不要平移，总是跟拍，但平移就像，要么让他们离开画面再回来，要么跟着他们拍。所以我记得在马丁·斯科塞斯那部有丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯的电影首映式上
Gangs of New York was that way and Joe Ethan and I were at the premiere and the movie ended and Ethan turned to me and said, why was that movie so bad? And I said, too much panning. The camera just moved left to right and then you left to right or in and out. Let me ask you, Barry, so you did so much storyboarding and planning out, you know, and you had all this stuff, all this preparation. What was that like when you would do all that preparation and then you'd get there on the day and things would be different because actors have different interpretations or whatever,
《纽约黑帮》就是那样，乔尔、伊桑和我在首映式上，电影结束了，伊桑转向我说，为什么那部电影那么烂？我说，平移太多了。摄像机只是从左到右移动，然后你从左到右，或者进进出出。让我问你，巴里，所以你做了那么多的故事板和规划，你知道，你做了所有的准备工作。当你做了所有的准备工作，然后到了那一天，事情变得不同了，因为演员有不同的解读或者其他什么，那是什么感觉？
as much as you want to kind of get them into an area that sort of fix this preconceived notions that you have of the scene, once it starts changing, what is that like as a cinematographer, but more importantly as a director when you've done all that planning and things change? Is that frustrating to you or do you enjoy it? I don't let things change. I knew you were going to say that. Next question. I mean, really, you know, you design this thing and you need the actor to be looking
尽管你想把他们带到一个区域，某种程度上修正你对场景的先入为主的观念，一旦它开始改变，作为摄影师，但更重要的是作为导演，当你做了所有的计划而事情发生了变化时，那是什么感觉？这让你感到沮丧吗，还是你很享受？我不让事情改变。我就知道你会这么说。下一个问题。我是说，真的，你知道，你设计了这个东西，你需要演员看着
out the window so you can rack focus and see the calorie coming. And the actor says, I wouldn't look at the window. I would be looking at the person I'm angry at, then you have to say, just look at the out the window. Yeah. I just, I know it's horrible. There's nothing worse than designing all this stuff and then having to change it. So I just don't change it.
窗外，这样你就可以拉焦，看到卡路里进来。而演员说，我不会看窗外。我会看着我生气的对象，然后你必须说，就看着窗外。是的。我只是，我知道这很糟糕。没有什么比设计了所有这些东西然后不得不改变它更糟糕的了。所以我只是不改变它。
I mean, I was working with Will and Will kept saying, I have a broken leg. I can't do this. And I said, just do it. Yeah. You can do it. So I was about to say this. So a couple of years ago, Barry asked me to do Lemony Snicket and come up to Vancouver for a week with Colby Smulders.
我是说，我和威尔一起工作，威尔一直说，我腿断了。我做不到。我说，就做吧。是的。你能做到的。所以我正要说这个。所以几年前，巴里让我做《雷蒙·斯尼奇的不幸历险》，去温哥华和寇碧·史莫德斯待了一周。
And I was really excited to go and then I hurt my knee and I had to have knee surgery. So I was about, I called Barry up and I said, listen, I'm not going to be able to come up. I got to get knee surgery next week. And then you want me to start the next week and there's no way I will have had MCL surgery. And Barry said, well, you got to come. And I said, no, no, no, I don't think you're here when I'm saying like I'm having knee surgery and I can't do it. He says, well, you got to figure it out.
我真的很兴奋去，然后我伤了膝盖，我不得不做膝盖手术。所以我正要，我打电话给巴里说，听着，我没法去了。我下周得做膝盖手术。然后你想要我下周开始，我不可能做完MCL手术。巴里说，嗯，你得来。我说，不，不，不，我不认为你在这里，当我说我做了膝盖手术时，我做不到。他说，嗯，你得想办法。
You got to come. He says, here's where I, here's where you're going to contradict yourself. You said, I'll, I'll change all your blocking so that you're sitting all the time. Right. I went like, God damn it. God, he's making it too easy for me. Like he's, and I just, I love the guy. So I'm like, what am I going to, so I finally, I relented it.
你得来。他说，这是我，这是你要自相矛盾的地方。你说，我会改变你所有的走位，这样你一直坐着。对。我当时想，该死。天哪，他让我太轻松了。就像他，我就是爱这个家伙。所以我说，我能怎么办，所以我终于，我妥协了。
And I said, okay, I'll do it. And I can't believe that I did cause I was really in pain and my knee was very swollen. Here's the best part. I get up to Vancouver. I have to go through the airport in a wheelchair and my legs all swollen up. I get there six, six a.m. the next day on set, banging on my trailer. Barry comes in first thing before he even says hello, he goes, you should have asked me.
我说，好吧，我做。我不敢相信我做了，因为我真的很痛苦，我的膝盖肿得很厉害。这是最好的部分。我到了温哥华。我必须坐轮椅穿过机场，我的腿肿得厉害。我第二天早上六点到片场，敲我的拖车。巴里进来了，第一件事，在他打招呼之前，他说，你应该问我的。
I would have told you not to have surgery on your knee, but I mean, I'm in pain. I'm there for him and he's berating me for having knee surgery. And we will be right back. Let me ask you something. You're, you've done so many different kinds of projects and you, and, and brilliantly what draws you to one and not another? Like is there a recipe that you look for or, or what is it? Yeah.
我会告诉你不要做膝盖手术的，但我，我是说，我很痛苦。我在那里是为了他，而他却因为我做了膝盖手术而责骂我。我们马上回来。让我问你一件事。你，你做了这么多不同类型的项目，你，而且，而且出色地，是什么吸引你选择一个而不是另一个？就像你寻找的配方，或者，或者那是什么？是的。
I'm a really big fan of world building. So whether it's pushing daisies or men in black or Adams family or a series of unfortunate events, there's something sort of quirky and off about all that stuff. It's not, it's both real and not quite real. I also really only want to do comedies. I mean, there are a couple of things I tried to do that weren't comedies, but I never could get them made. But so I like comedies, but I like world building.
我真的是世界构建的超级粉丝。所以无论是《灵指神探》还是《黑衣人》或《亚当斯一家》或《雷蒙·斯尼奇的不幸历险》，所有这些东西都有点古怪和离奇。它既真实又不完全真实。我也真的只想拍喜剧。我是说，有几件事我尝试做但不是喜剧，但我从来没能把它们拍出来。但所以，我喜欢喜剧，但我喜欢世界构建。
So everything sort of and quirkiness a little bit. So, so that's what I look for. I, I could never do a legal drama, you know, episode seven of a legal drama. Yeah. I guess. And you like style too. Like, you know, get shorty was very stylized, very stylistic. Like it was a very, which was a huge hit.
所以一切都有点，还有一点古怪。所以，所以这就是我寻找的。我，我永远无法拍法律剧，你知道，法律剧的第七集。是的。我想。而且你也喜欢风格。就像，你知道，《矮子当道》非常有风格，非常有格调。就像它是一部非常，这是一个巨大的成功。
And I think it was one of those films that really got people's attention when it came out. It was such a great film and Travolta was just making his comeback, right? At that time. Yeah. And I cast him right before Pulp Fiction came out. So Pulp Fiction really started him again and then get shorty helped. It took us seven years to get that made.
而且我认为它是那些真正引起人们注意的电影之一。它是一部很棒的电影，特拉沃尔塔当时正在复出，对吧？在那时。是的。我在《低俗小说》上映前就选了他。所以《低俗小说》确实让他重新开始了，然后《矮子当道》帮了忙。我们花了七年时间才把它拍出来。
DeVito and I were pitching that show for seven years. No one wanted to make it. There had never been a successful Elmore Leonard movie based on of his novels. And no one wanted to make an inside Hollywood thing. So that's an example of how wrong Hollywood can be sometimes. With stuff that with the world building, obviously, it demands that there's a coalition of multiple departments, you know, inside the production design and the cinematography. Obviously the music and the performance all to manage this unique tone that you're trying
德维托和我推销那个节目推销了七年。没人想拍它。从来没有一部基于埃尔莫·伦纳德小说的成功电影。而且没人想拍一部关于好莱坞内部的东西。所以这就是好莱坞有时会错得多么离谱的一个例子。对于世界构建的东西，显然，它要求多个部门的联盟，你知道，在制作设计和摄影内部。显然音乐和表演都要管理这种你试图传达给观众的独特基调
to deliver to the audience, both in a visual way and in an emotional way. Is there a favorite department that you like you like to deal with? Yeah. My favorite is the camera department. First of all, when I was a cameraman, I hated my department. I was winding and complaining and the camera is so heavy. I only ate and hung out with the grips and electrics because they're like manly men who like carry things and and and don't complain them in the PAs are the hardest workers on
无论是视觉上还是情感上。有没有你最喜欢的部门？是的。我最喜欢的是摄影部门。首先，当我还是摄影师时，我讨厌我的部门。我一直在抱怨，摄像机太重了。我只和场务和电工一起吃饭和闲逛，因为他们就像喜欢搬东西的男子汉，而且不抱怨，他们是片场最努力工作的人。
set. Yeah. I hated the my own department and now as a director for me, it starts with production design and that's usually Bo Welch, who did our three things years on a series. I love Bo Welch. I did cat in the hat with him. He was. Yeah.
是的。我讨厌我自己的部门，现在作为导演，对我来说，它始于制作设计，通常是博·威尔奇，他在系列剧中做了我们三年的东西。我爱博·威尔奇。我和他一起拍了《戴帽子的猫》。他是。是的。
Bo directed that and had just a terrible time, as you know, but tough time with the actors. That's what I heard. Yeah. I think it was a lot of pushback from a lot of whiny talking about departments. I would look out the window. I'd look at the person. Yeah. Yeah.
博执导了那部电影，正如你所知，经历了一段糟糕的时光，但与演员相处得很艰难。我听说是这样。是的。我想有很多来自很多爱抱怨的部门的阻力。我会看向窗外。我会看向那个人。是的。是的。
My character wouldn't even have a window. I hate hats. Yeah. I mean, is there like, are there has there been people that you've kind of gotten into a discussion, a heated discussion with, but you ended up really kind of admiring that, you know, afterwards? Is there some? No, I'm going to answer for Barry.
我的角色甚至不会有窗户。我讨厌帽子。是的。我是说，有没有像，有没有人你曾经进行过讨论，激烈的讨论，但你最后真的很欣赏，你知道，事后？有没有一些？不，我要替巴里回答。
No. No. I had to run in with Tom Sizemore on on big trouble. He wanted to be in a comedy and I said, all right, I'll hire you under two conditions. You have to do whatever I tell you to do and you're not allowed to hit me. And he agreed to those, he agreed to those notes. And on the first day of shooting, big trouble, I called him into my camper at the end of the day and I said, I've got to fire you.
不。不。我在《大麻烦》上和汤姆·塞兹摩尔有过冲突。他想演喜剧，我说，好吧，我雇你，但有两个条件。你必须做我告诉你做的任何事，而且你不准打我。他同意了这些，他同意了这些要求。在拍摄《大麻烦》的第一天，我在一天结束时把他叫到我的拖车里，我说，我得解雇你。
And he said, why? I said, and you can't hit me. And he said, well, maybe. And then I said, here's the problem. You're trying to be funny. What's that tick? What's that limp? And he said, well, it's a comedy.
他说，为什么？我说，而且你不能打我。他说，嗯，也许吧。然后我说，问题是这样的。你试图变得有趣。那是什么抽动？那是什么跛行？他说，嗯，这是喜剧。
I said, just play the scene. The scene is funny. Don't you be funny. Right. Wait, Jason, can I see your pants again? Oh yeah. These are pajamas. Yeah.
我说，就演好场景。场景很有趣。不要你变得有趣。对。等等，杰森，我能再看看你的裤子吗？哦，是的。这是睡衣。是的。
Yeah. I thought that. I just. Jason has hit such a level of fuck it. He gave up so long ago and it's so embarrassing. And as his friend, it's worrying to watch him go down and deteriorate so quickly. Sorry. Go ahead, John.
是的。我以为是。我只是。杰森已经达到了这种“去他妈的”的境界。他很久以前就放弃了，这太尴尬了。作为他的朋友，看着他如此迅速地堕落和恶化，我很担心。抱歉。继续，约翰。
I just want to kind of along these lines, but go ahead. Yeah. Because I've never met you and I'm such a huge fan of your work. What I'm hearing is you have a very specific process. And me as an actor listening to you, is there a middle ground you enjoy working with actors? Or is it really just like, this is how this should go. Everybody just show up, stand where you're supposed to stand, wear what you're supposed to wear, and say what you're supposed to say.
我只是想沿着这些思路，但你继续。是的。因为我从没见过你，我是你作品的超级粉丝。我听到的是你有一个非常具体的流程。作为一个听你说话的演员，你喜欢和演员合作的中间地带吗？还是真的就像，事情就该这样。每个人都出现，站在你应该站的地方，穿你应该穿的衣服，说你应该说的话。
It really depends on the script and the actors. If there are certain actors that are really smart and the script isn't like on Get Shorty, I didn't let anyone change your word. You know, Travolta would say, can I say can't instead of cannot? And I would go, no, it's got to be cannot. It's got to be really specific. And then there are other times when you're working with Will and the scene's no good. You say, Will, what do you got?
这真的取决于剧本和演员。如果有些演员真的很聪明，而剧本不像《矮子当道》那样，我没让任何人改一个字。你知道，特拉沃尔塔会说，我能说“can't”而不是“cannot”吗？我会说，不，必须是“cannot”。必须非常具体。然后还有其他时候，当你和威尔一起工作，场景不好时。你说，威尔，你有什么想法？
You know, so there's a little bit of that. And then I've learned. Will Smith. Will Smith. You mean Will Smith? Will Smith. Or Will Arnett. Anyone named Will.
你知道，所以有一点那种情况。然后我学会了。威尔·史密斯。威尔·史密斯。你是说威尔·史密斯？威尔·史密斯。或者威尔·阿奈特。任何叫威尔的人。
Will Arnett is, you put a 21 millimeter lens in front of Will, and no matter what he says, and it could be literally Meryl Streep's speech from Sophie's Choice, and somehow it's going to be hilarious. Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely. Speaking of those 21 inch lens, so I remember Barry telling me once that when we were doing somebody's Snicket that he had our friend Don Johnson on there and Don asked you what kind of lens you, he heard somebody, he heard you say to the DP, put a 21 on, and he said,
威尔·阿奈特是，你在威尔面前放一个21毫米镜头，无论他说什么，即使是梅丽尔·斯特里普在《苏菲的选择》里的演讲，不知何故它都会变得非常搞笑。是的，绝对。绝对。说到那些21英寸镜头，我记得巴里曾经告诉我，当我们在做《雷蒙·斯尼奇》时，他让我们的朋友唐·约翰逊在那里，唐问你用什么镜头，他听到有人，他听到你对摄影指导说，装一个21毫米的，他说，
hold up. He says, you're not, you're not shooting me with a 21. Right. Yeah. And I was like, and you, so we laughed about it. And he was like, no, I'm, you're not shooting me and blah, blah, blah, he's a handsome guy and stuff. And then I was like, so Don Johnson doesn't get to have the, but I get the 21 on me,
等等。他说，你不是，你不是用21毫米拍我。对。是的。我当时想，我们对此笑了。他就像，不，我，你不是在拍我，巴拉巴拉，他是个帅哥之类的。然后我就想，所以唐·约翰逊不能有那个，但我却要在我的蠢脸上用21毫米镜头。
on my dumb face. You do have a dumb face, which is so wonderful about you. Thank you. Let me tell you a quick story about your dumb face. Recently, just this past weekend was at an event and I was sitting next to John Hamm, who I know just slightly a little bit. And I said to John, you know, there's a certain subset of actors. There's you, Patrick Warburton and Will Arnett that are all incredibly handsome with these
你确实有一张蠢脸，这正是你如此美妙的地方。谢谢。让我给你讲一个关于你蠢脸的简短故事。最近，就在上周末，我在一个活动上，我坐在约翰·哈姆旁边，我对他有一点点了解。我对约翰说，你知道，有一类演员。有你、帕特里克·沃伯顿和威尔·阿奈特，你们都非常帅，有着
deep, low voices and you so get comedy by, you're so flat, you're so wonderful. And John's response was, wow, to be put in the same context with Patrick Warburton. Thank you. So I thought I should share that with you, Will. Listen, I'm happy to avoid the hit and I know him, so I would have texted him immediately. But I will say that you, you know, you do have such a, I love how specific you are with your, I don't know, your concepts and your theories on comedy and filmmaking and all that stuff.
深沉、低沉的声音，而且你们非常懂喜剧，你们太平淡了，你们太棒了。约翰的回答是，哇，能和帕特里克·沃伯顿相提并论。谢谢。所以我认为我应该和你分享这一点，威尔。听着，我很乐意避免那次打击，而且我认识他，所以我本来会立刻给他发短信的。但我得说，你，你知道，你确实有这样一种，我喜欢你对你的，我不知道，你的喜剧和电影制作的概念和理论，以及所有这些东西的特定性。
I just, I've always loved that. That's neither here nor there. I just kind of wanted to say that I've always enjoyed that about you because it, it does when you get on set and you have, and we'll have a brief conversation because anytime I ask you a question, you've always got an answer for it, which is great. And then you go, as an actor, you go, oh, okay, well, that makes sense. And then you go ahead and do it. Right.
我只是，我一直很喜欢那个。那无关紧要。我只是想说，我一直很欣赏你这一点，因为它确实，当你到了片场，你有，我们会进行简短的交谈，因为每当我问你问题时，你总是有答案，这很棒。然后你走，作为演员，你走，哦，好吧，那有道理。然后你就继续做。对。
It should also be noted that the footnote on that having surgery story was about 10 days after my surgery, the first time I walked without crutches, I walked on camera for Barry using this cane that was made for me by the prop department. And that was the first time I walked. I was like, Jesus Christ, I can't believe I'm doing this. So Barry, I want to get into your book that you've written called Barry Sonnenfeld, Call Your Mother, which is a great title. And it's actually, it's actually a quote from, is it a quote from a concert you were
还应该指出的是，关于那个做手术故事的脚注是，在我手术后大约10天，我第一次不拄拐杖走路，我为巴里在摄像机前走动，用的是道具部门为我制作的拐杖。那是我第一次走路。我当时想，天哪，我不敢相信我在做这个。所以巴里，我想深入了解你写的书，叫《巴里·索南菲尔德，给你妈打电话》，这是一个很棒的书名。而且它实际上，它实际上是来自你当时参加的一场音乐会的一句引语
at? Is that, is that what happened? Is that where the title came from? Yeah. So I'm 17 years old, 19,600 people, Madison Square Garden, 2.20 in the morning. That's important that it was 2.20. Jimi Hendrix warming up for the second time. It was the first piece concert that had been Peter, Paul and Mary and all these other
吗？是那样吗？书名是那样来的吗？是的。所以我17岁，19600人，麦迪逊广场花园，凌晨2点20分。凌晨2点20分这一点很重要。吉米·亨德里克斯第二次热身。那是第一场和平音乐会，有彼得、保罗和玛丽以及所有这些其他
groups. And at 2.20 in the morning, while Jimi Hendrix is warming up over the PA system at Madison Square Garden, comes the announcement, Barry Sonnenfeld, Call Your Mother, which, so here's what happened. So first of all, I started to cry because I knew my father was dead because how else you convince anyone? So I start to cry, I stand up so that I announced to my section of blue seats at the garden that I am Barry Sonnenfeld by standing up.
团体。在凌晨2点20分，当吉米·亨德里克斯在麦迪逊广场花园的扩音系统上热身时，传来了广播，“巴里·索南菲尔德，给你妈打电话”，这，所以发生了什么事。所以首先，我开始哭，因为我知道我父亲死了，因为除此之外你怎么能说服任何人？所以我开始哭，我站起来，以便向花园里蓝色座位区的我的区域宣布我是巴里·索南菲尔德。
So now the chant of, the garden chant of Barry, Barry starts to sort of envelop the upper part of the garden. I get to the pay phone, call my mother weeping uncontrollably, mom who died, my mother says, I thought you died, you said you would be home at two, it's 2.20. I said, right, but didn't they tell you the concert was still going on? Yes, but they couldn't guarantee you were there. So she also said if I went away to sleep away school, others call it college, she would commit suicide.
所以现在花园里“巴里，巴里”的口号开始笼罩花园的上部。我跑到公用电话，哭着给我妈打电话，妈妈以为我死了，我妈说，我以为你死了，你说你两点会回家，现在是2点20分。我说，对，但他们没告诉你音乐会还在进行吗？是的，但他们不能保证你在那里。所以她还说如果我去外地学校，别人称之为大学，她就会自杀。
So I spent three years living at home in Washington Heights attending NYU Uptown in the Bronx. And then when I was going to be a senior, I transferred to Hampshire college where I met Ken Burns thinking, I go away to college and my mother commits suicide, two birds, one stone, and then she totally rednecks and doesn't commit suicide, could never count on her. No, it's tough to count on people. So dad was not dead then, right? Dad was just worried with mom.
所以我花了三年时间住在华盛顿高地的家里，在布朗克斯上纽约大学。然后当我快要大四时，我转学到了汉普郡学院，在那里我遇到了肯·伯恩斯，心想，我去外地上大学，我妈自杀，一箭双雕，然后她完全反悔了，没有自杀，永远指望不上她。不，指望人很难。所以爸爸当时还没死，对吧？爸爸只是担心妈妈。
Dad was having his multiple affairs, so was rarely home until later in the night when he would always open up a container of breakstone, sour cream, and either put bananas and brown sugar or cucumbers in it. And that was his second dinner after he had dinner with whatever woman he was having sex with at the time. And who could blame him? I wanted to pick your brain about electronics, consumer products, because I've really enjoyed your reviews of those on your many letterman appearances.
爸爸当时在搞他的多次外遇，所以直到深夜才回家，那时他总是会打开一盒Breakstone酸奶油，要么放香蕉和红糖，要么放黄瓜。那是他和他当时正在发生性关系的任何女人吃完晚餐后的第二顿晚餐。谁能怪他呢？我想请教你关于电子产品、消费品的问题，因为我真的很喜欢你在大卫·莱特曼节目中对它们的评论。
Is there something we should really be keeping our eye on right now that you're super fond of? You know, for 10 years I had this column in Esquire magazine called The Digital Man, and it would review things all the time. And now I'm so sick of it. I just ordered the iPhone 13 because I have an 11 and it's cracked. But I don't know. Maybe it's drone.
现在有什么我们应该真正关注的你非常喜欢的东西吗？你知道，有10年时间我在《时尚先生》杂志上有一个专栏叫《数字人》，它一直在评论各种东西。现在我厌倦了。我刚订了iPhone 13，因为我有一个11，而且屏幕碎了。但我不知道。也许是无人机。
I mean, does anyone use still cameras anymore? Well, it wasn't at Annie Liebowitz that said that somebody asked her, you know, if I was going to buy a camera, what would be the best camera to buy? And she said, just get an iPhone. Those cameras are incredible. And you know, now on the 13, the video now has that shallow depth of field that the portrait mode on the still camera has. So you can shoot video with a real shallow depth of field, which is nice.
我是说，还有人使用静态照相机吗？嗯，不是安妮·莱博维茨说的吗，有人问她，你知道，如果我要买一台相机，买什么相机最好？她说，买个iPhone就行了。那些相机太不可思议了。而且你知道，现在在13上，视频现在有了静态相机人像模式那种浅景深。所以你可以用真正的浅景深拍摄视频，这很好。
It looks really cinematic. I like lots of depth of field. That's where the 21 comes in. But yeah, it does let you do that. I mean, you direct with longer lenses than I do, but your stuff is in comedy. But even when we go wider, you know, we shoot wide open because I like that, that shallower stuff. But so yeah, so you're ever, you can see everything in, in, in the way that you light
看起来确实很有电影感。我喜欢大景深。这就是21毫米镜头派上用场的地方。但确实，它能让你做到这一点。我的意思是，你用的镜头比我用的长，但你拍的是喜剧。不过即使我们用广角，你知道，我们也会全开光圈，因为我喜欢那种更浅的景深。所以，是的，你可以看到一切，包括你的布光方式
and the stop you work, you work at. Yeah. Yes. And I'll say one thing. That's why I track so much because I shoot with these wide angle lenses. So everything's in focus. So you have to tell the audience where to look. So I do that by moving, you know, tracking in often.
以及你所使用的光圈。是的。我要说一件事。这就是我为什么经常移动镜头的原因，因为我用的是广角镜头。所以一切都在焦点内。因此你必须告诉观众看哪里。所以我通过移动，你知道，经常推拉镜头来做到这一点。
And I also center punch. I center punch everything and it drives all the camera operators. I work with crazy and then over time they get used to it. What is your, what is your thought on in, in comedy on keeping, you know, multiple characters in the same frame and, or, and, or using coverage in comedy? Because I think it's become this thing increasingly over the years where, where you're constantly cutting to a single. And, and for me, it takes me out of it completely.
而且我喜欢居中构图。我把所有东西都放在画面正中央，这让和我合作的摄影师们都快疯了，但久而久之他们也就习惯了。你对喜剧中保持多个角色在同一个画面里，或者使用覆盖镜头有什么看法？因为我觉得这些年来，人们越来越倾向于不断切换到单人镜头。对我来说，这完全让我出戏。
And I had this argument on the set with the director recently on this thing we were doing this sort of improvie show that we've got coming out on Netflix. And I was saying, I really want to make sure to as much as we can see these characters in the same frame reacting off each other because that's the funniest, right? Well, Will, why would you not hire me to direct that? Because I would think that you're too busy and you're, you're a big shot and you live in Canada. I'm not too busy and I'm not a big shot and I'd love to work with you.
最近我在片场和一位导演争论过这件事，我们正在拍一部即将在Netflix上线的即兴表演秀。我说，我真的想尽可能确保这些角色在同一个画面里，互相做出反应，因为那才是最搞笑的，对吧？好吧，威尔，你为什么不雇我来导演呢？因为我觉得你太忙了，你是大人物，而且你住在加拿大。我不忙，我也不是什么大人物，我很乐意和你合作。
So let me say any of you. Okay. Here's the thing. That goes double for me. Okay. Well, send me something. Triple for me. Okay.
那让我说……好吧。事情是这样的。这话对我来说加倍适用。好吧，给我发点东西。对我来说是三倍。好吧。
Sean wins. Yeah. Comedy plays out in two shot and masters. I think close ups are the enemy of the, of comedy. I think cutting to the punchline is the enemy of the comedy. And that's why I have actors talk fast because by talking fast and pacing it up, there's nothing lazier than trying to create pace in post production, create pace on the set. And by creating pace on the set, you get to play scenes out in two shots.
肖恩赢了。是的。喜剧是在双人镜头和全景镜头中展开的。我认为特写镜头是喜剧的敌人。我认为切到笑点是喜剧的敌人。这就是为什么我让演员说话快一点，因为通过说话快和加快节奏，没有什么比在后期制作中创造节奏更懒惰的了，要在片场创造节奏。通过在片场创造节奏，你可以在双人镜头中完成场景。
I mean, Sean, look at Shmega Dune. There are very few close ups and all the dance numbers you see people from head to toe. I was going to say comedy aside, even in choreography and it speaks to Shmega Dune, even choreography, I hate when they cut in on choreography too. It's like, no, they're all dancing at the same time. I want to see what everybody's doing at the same time. Absolutely. You look at Preston Sturgis or Howard Hawks comedy.
我是说，肖恩，看看《矮子当道》。几乎没有特写镜头，所有的舞蹈片段你都能看到人们从头到脚的样子。我正想说，撇开喜剧不谈，即使在编舞中也是如此，这和《矮子当道》有关，我讨厌他们在编舞时切镜头。就像是，不，他们都在同时跳舞。我想同时看到每个人在做什么。绝对是这样。看看普雷斯顿·斯特奇斯或霍华德·霍克斯的喜剧。
You look at bringing up, baby, you have Catherine Hepburn calling Cary Grant, Mr. Bones. And that's not his name. You have Cary Grant in her aunt's bathrobe trying to butt in. And it only plays out because you play out in the master. You see action and reaction in the same shot. And the other thing that goes with that will is that you never want two funny people in your scene. You need Jerry Lewis and Dean Martin.
看看《育婴奇谭》，凯瑟琳·赫本叫加里·格兰特“骨头先生”。那不是他的名字。加里·格兰特穿着她姑妈的浴袍试图插话。这之所以有效，是因为你在全景镜头中表演。你在同一个镜头里看到了动作和反应。还有一点，威尔，你永远不要在场景里放两个搞笑的人。你需要杰瑞·刘易斯和迪恩·马丁。
You need George Burns and Gracie Allen. And at the start of Men in Black, Tommy Lee Jones kept trying to be funny. And I kept saying, Tommy, government issue, no comedy, totally flat. You don't think this is funny. And he had never been in a comedy before and hated me for 20 weeks. His agent would call me up and say, you only want Will Smith to be funny. You don't want Tommy to be funny. I said, Tommy will be funnier than Will.
你需要乔治·伯恩斯和格雷西·艾伦。在《黑衣人》开头，汤米·李·琼斯一直试图搞笑。我一直说，汤米，政府公职人员，不要搞笑，完全平淡。你觉得这不好笑。他以前从没演过喜剧，恨了我20周。他的经纪人会打电话给我说，你只想让威尔·史密斯搞笑。你不想让汤米搞笑。我说，汤米会比威尔更好笑。
The biggest laugh in the scene is the reaction, not the action. You cut to Meg Ryan faking an orgasm in When Harry Met Sally, which I show at Rob. And as funny as she is faking the orgasm, you cut to Billy Crystal doing nothing, just reacting. And the left goes from 100 dB to 120 dB. So it's all about the master. It's all about. And the only reason you ever even want to cover it is in case you want to combine the first
场景中最大的笑点是反应，而不是动作。你在《当哈利遇到莎莉》中切到梅格·瑞恩假装高潮，我给罗伯看了。尽管她假装高潮很搞笑，但你切到比利·克里斯托什么都不做，只是做出反应。笑声从100分贝变成了120分贝。所以一切都在于全景镜头。一切都在于此。你唯一想要覆盖镜头的理由是，以防你想结合第一
half of this. But play it in two shots and wide shots. Imagine explaining how comedy work and comedy filmmaking works and you get to throw in the fact that you shot When Harry Met Sally. And you omit the fact that you also shot big and you omit the fact that you shot throw mama from the train. You always forget how crazy your resume is very amazing things you've done. Yeah.
半部分。但要在双人镜头和广角镜头中表演。想象一下，解释喜剧是如何运作的，喜剧电影制作是如何运作的，你还能顺便提一下你拍摄了《当哈利遇到莎莉》。你忽略了你还拍摄了《飞越未来》，你还忽略了你拍摄了《扔掉妈妈下火车》。你总是忘记你的简历有多疯狂，你做过非常了不起的事情。是的。
Fine. It's true. We'll be right back. All right. Back to the show. Because you're such a huge fan of comedy. Is there somebody now or a show now or what's out there now that you're kind of really into and like talking about?
好吧。这是真的。我们马上回来。好了。回到节目。因为你是喜剧的超级粉丝。现在有没有什么人，或者什么节目，或者现在有什么东西是你真的很喜欢并乐于谈论的？
What's funny? I mean, I love JoJo Rabbit. I thought that was, I mean, and the genius of JoJo Rabbit is that you can laugh at Hitler because he exists only in the kids mind. So there is no actual Hitler, you know, and also he was a buffoon. Yeah. So I love JoJo Rabbit. Sweden.
什么好笑？我是说，我喜欢《乔乔的异想世界》。我觉得那部电影，我是说，《乔乔的异想世界》的天才之处在于你可以嘲笑希特勒，因为他只存在于孩子的脑海中。所以没有真正的希特勒，你知道，而且他是个小丑。是的。所以我喜欢《乔乔的异想世界》。瑞典。
I've been watching the Bureau. I don't know if you guys have seen that. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Which is not funny, but every one of those actors are so real and I don't understand it. Jason, I was telling you about it. Kassavitz is the lead and he's a great director in his own right and he directed, hates back
我一直在看《办公室》。我不知道你们有没有看过。哦，是的。是的。那并不好笑，但每一个演员都那么真实，我不明白。杰森，我跟你说过。卡索维茨是主角，他本身就是一位伟大的导演，他导演了《恨》，回到
in the nineties, but he's a great, great actor. He was in Amelie. That second, second or third season, the last episode is the first, I think it's the only episode of television where I would legitimately sat on the edge of my sofa being like, what is going on? It was so gripping. What is that? On Netflix?
九十年代，但他是一位非常非常伟大的演员。他出演了《天使爱美丽》。第二季或第三季，最后一集是第一集，我想这是电视上唯一一集让我真正坐在沙发边缘，心想，到底发生了什么？太扣人心弦了。那是什么？在Netflix上吗？
No, you have to buy it on iTunes. So it's going to cost you 20 bucks a year, but it's, it's worth it. So I don't see a lot of comedy that I like because so much of comedy is now this sort of improv stuff where they shoot with three or four cameras and you see part of someone's nose and you see, and it's done through improv and I'm just, I'm not that guy. Yeah. Well, because it's so hard to construct it in the first place. And so it's much easier to just make commentary on it and there's a lot of like veneer of funny
不，你必须在iTunes上买。所以它会花你20美元，但它，它很值得。所以我没看到多少我喜欢的喜剧，因为现在的喜剧大多是那种即兴表演，他们用三四台摄像机拍摄，你只能看到某人的鼻子的一部分，你看到，而且是通过即兴表演完成的，我不是那种人。是的。嗯，因为首先构建它太难了。所以更容易只是对它进行评论，而且外面有很多像喜剧外壳的东西
out there, which, which without actual jokes and cause the hardest thing to do is write good jokes. Barry, I want to ask you a little bit cause Sean, you had kind of touched on it. This idea of like who, you know, moments that you had thing or you didn't get along with people or you didn't. Yeah. One of the things that struck me when you came into my trailer that day up in Vancouver and you told me that I shouldn't have had my knee surgery, you talked to me a little
，没有真正的笑话，因为最难的事情是写出好的笑话。巴里，我想问你一点，因为肖恩，你刚才提到了。这种想法，你知道，你经历过的时刻，或者你和别人相处不来，或者你没有。是的。那天在温哥华你走进我的拖车时，有一件事让我印象深刻，你告诉我我不应该做膝盖手术，你跟我谈了一点
bit about this moment that you had had when you were experienced and you mentioned you had sciatica, when you'd had a lot of sort of physical pain in that moment that you kind of got over that. And it really impacted me that morning when you told me this story, maybe you could tell these guys a little bit about that. You mean how I lost my pain on men in black three by yelling at someone? Was that the one? Yeah.
关于你经历过的那一刻，你提到你有坐骨神经痛，当你在那一刻承受了很多身体上的痛苦时，你克服了它。那天早上你给我讲这个故事时，它真的影响了我，也许你可以给这些人讲讲。你是说我是怎么在《黑衣人3》中通过对某人大喊大叫而治好我的疼痛的吗？是那个吗？是的。
Yeah. That's one. So, so I used to yell and I'll be specific. It was a scene in the first men in black where Will Smith and Tommy Lee Jones arrive at headquarters for the first time and come down that elevator and we pull back from them and we reveal sort of the terminal, you know, both Welsh designed it and we designed it as if it's an airplane terminal. It's where aliens come in and get booked and all that.
是的。那是其中之一。所以，我过去常大喊大叫，我会具体说明。那是第一部《黑衣人》中的一个场景，威尔·史密斯和汤米·李·琼斯第一次到达总部，从电梯里下来，我们从他们身上拉开镜头，我们揭示了终端，你知道，博·威尔士设计了它，我们把它设计得就像一个飞机航站楼。那是外星人进来并被登记的地方，诸如此类。
And I said to the special effects crew, look, I don't want Tommy to yell at me. I got yelled at by him and Gene Hackman so often, Gene Hackman on, I just don't want to be yelled at. What time do you guys need to get here to make sure that elevator is going to be working tomorrow morning? Oh, boss, what time are they going to be ready? They'll be ready at 10 a.m. Oh, eight is good.
我对特效组说，听着，我不希望汤米对我大喊大叫。我经常被他和吉恩·哈克曼大喊大叫，吉恩·哈克曼在，我只是不想被大喊大叫。你们几点需要到这里以确保电梯明天早上能工作？哦，老板，他们什么时候准备好？他们会在上午10点准备好。哦，8点很好。
I said, let's make it four a.m. Get here at four. They said, no, no, we'll be ready. We'll be ready. I said, don't worry about overtime. Take as much time as you, oh, it's good. So of course they're not ready. It's 10.
我说，让我们定在凌晨4点。4点到这里。他们说，不，不，我们会准备好的。我们会准备好的。我说，别担心加班。花尽可能多的时间，哦，很好。所以当然他们没准备好。10点了。
It's 11. And I yell in front of the whole crew, guys, guys, I gave you what as much time as you want. I begged you and I'm yelling, right? And sweetie, my wife, sweetie turns me and says, they felt bad before you yelled at them. They knew they screwed up, but now by you yelling at them, they get to feel that you're the asshole instead of them screwing up. So in 1997, I stopped ever yelling at anyone again. And for the last 30 years, I have profound sciatica because sciatica is brought on by
11点了。我在整个剧组面前大喊，伙计们，伙计们，我给了你们想要的所有时间。我求过你们，我在大喊，对吧？而斯威蒂，我的妻子，斯威蒂转向我说，在你对他们大喊大叫之前，他们已经感到很糟糕了。他们知道他们搞砸了，但现在因为你对他们大喊大叫，他们觉得你才是那个混蛋，而不是他们搞砸了。所以从1997年起，我再也没有对任何人吼过。在过去的30年里，我有严重的坐骨神经痛，因为坐骨神经痛是由
unconscious narcissistic rage. You're keeping your anger inside of you instead of expressing it because you fear that if you express your anger, you're going to hurt someone you love or you'll get fired or whatever. In fact, I've cured both my wife and David Kepp's wife. David Kepp is a great screenwriter of sciatica by just explaining this to them and suggesting they need to yell at their partner and they'll get over sciatica, but I don't want to yell at sweetie. I don't want to yell at anyone anymore.
潜意识的自恋愤怒引起的。你把愤怒藏在心里，而不是表达出来，因为你害怕如果你表达愤怒，你会伤害你爱的人，或者你会被解雇，等等。事实上，我已经治好了我妻子和戴维·凯普妻子的坐骨神经痛。戴维·凯普是一位伟大的编剧，我只是向他们解释了这一点，并建议他们需要对他们的伴侣大喊大叫，他们就会克服坐骨神经痛，但我不想对斯威蒂大喊大叫。我不想再对任何人大喊大叫了。
So I have terrible sciatica. My sciatica on Men in Black 3 is so horrible because I so didn't get along with the producers and Sony was not being supportive of me. And we only shot the first third because we didn't have the rest of the script. And I kept saying, how can I have comedy callbacks if I don't know what the second and third acts are? I got to set up some stuff in the first act that's going to pay off in the third act, but I don't know what that third act is.
所以我坐骨神经痛很严重。我在《黑衣人3》时的坐骨神经痛太可怕了，因为我和制片人相处得不好，索尼也不支持我。我们只拍了前三分之一，因为我们没有剩下的剧本。我一直说，如果我不知道第二幕和第三幕是什么，我怎么能有喜剧的回调？我必须在第一幕中设置一些东西，在第三幕中会有回报，但我不知道第三幕是什么。
So I'm crawling up to Emma Thompson to give her direction and Emma says, oh, you're back so bad, you should see a physical therapist. And I said, no, unconscious narcissistic rage. And she says, oh, are you a patient of Dr. Sarno also because she has unconscious narcissistic rage? So the same back doctor. Okay. So now it's Christmas break.
所以我爬向艾玛·汤普森去指导她，艾玛说，哦，你的背太糟糕了，你应该去看物理治疗师。我说，不，潜意识的自恋愤怒。她说，哦，你也是萨诺医生的病人吗？因为她也有潜意识的自恋愤怒。所以是同一个背部医生。好吧。现在是圣诞假期。
I want to hire David Kepp to come in and fix our script. The producers don't want to. I'm on the phone with the producers and Amy Pascal and Doug Belgrad formerly of Sony. And the producer says to me, cause he doesn't want to hire David Kepp cause Kepp will only do it if he only has to work with me and not these producers. And the punchline is, is going to be from Dr. Strangelove. Just so you're prepared. The producer says to me, let's face it, Barry, the last 10 years of your life have been a
我想雇戴维·凯普进来修改我们的剧本。制片人不想。我正在和制片人以及索尼的前任艾米·帕斯卡尔和道格·贝尔格拉德通电话。制片人对我说，因为他不想雇戴维·凯普，因为凯普只有在只和他工作而不是这些制片人工作时才会做。笑点将来自《奇爱博士》。为了让你有准备。制片人对我说，面对现实吧，巴里，你过去10年的生活是一个
professional and personal failure. Jesus. So I say to him, fuck you, Walter, fuck you, fuck all of you. And I hang up and I leave, but I screamed it and I leave the room and I walked downstairs to my wife and just like the end of Dr. Strangelove, I said to sweetie, I can walk. My sciatica had all gone away and I could literally walk and I had no pain because I expressed that anger. It lasted a couple of weeks and of course, and it came back again, but for two weeks,
职业和个人的失败。天哪。所以我对他说，去你的，沃尔特，去你的，去你们所有人的。我挂断电话离开了，但我尖叫着离开了房间，我走到楼下找我妻子，就像《奇爱博士》的结尾一样，我对斯威蒂说，我可以走路了。我的坐骨神经痛全消失了，我真的可以走路了，我没有任何疼痛，因为我表达了那种愤怒。它持续了几个星期，当然，它又回来了，但有两周，
because I screamed at this person, my sciatica had totally gone away instantly. So Barry tells me that story and I'm lying in this trailer with an ice all over my knee and I'm like, okay, well, who am I mad at? I don't, listen, I'm happy to yell F you to somebody. I just don't know who it is. Try it. So you've written this book, Barry Seinfeld, Call Your Mother. What was that, what was the impetus for that?
因为我对着这个人尖叫，我的坐骨神经痛瞬间完全消失了。所以巴里告诉我那个故事，我躺在这个拖车里，膝盖上全是冰，我想，好吧，我生谁的气？我不，听着，我很乐意对某人喊“去你的”。我只是不知道那是谁。试试看。所以你写了这本书，《巴里·宋菲尔德，叫你妈妈》。那是什么，那是什么动力？
What was your, because you've done so many other things and you're like, well, I'm just going to write a book. Like how did that come about? So decades ago or 15 years ago, I wrote down, I was bored. So I wrote the porn chapter, which we talked about and I just put it away and then one weekend I gave it to my wife who used to be an editor and I said, hey, sweetie, read this. We were in bed and there's nothing I enjoy more in life than making my wife laugh. I love that.
你的，因为你做了这么多其他事情，你就像，好吧，我只是要写一本书。那是怎么发生的？所以几十年前或15年前，我写下来，我很无聊。所以我写了色情章节，我们谈过那个，我只是把它收起来了，然后一个周末我把它给了我以前是编辑的妻子，我说，嘿，斯威蒂，读读这个。我们在床上，生活中没有什么比让我妻子笑更让我享受的了。我喜欢那个。
Yeah. I just love, I just love that. And she was reading this in bed, shaking the bed and we weren't having sex or anything. Shaking the bed with laughter. And she said, this, it's great. It's just great. I said, great, put it away. Years go by and David Granger, who was the editor in chief of Esquire had left and become
是的。我只是喜欢，我只是喜欢那个。她在床上读这个，摇晃着床，我们没有做爱什么的。笑得摇晃着床。她说，这，太棒了。太棒了。我说，太棒了，收起来。几年过去了，曾任《时尚先生》主编的大卫·格兰杰离开了，成为了一名
a literary agent. He calls me up and he says, Hey, do you have a book in you? And I said, yeah, well, read this chapter. He reads a chapter. He says, give me two more. All right. Two more chapters. Wonder about my plane crash in Van Nuys airport where the crew abandoned me on the plane
文学经纪人。他打电话给我说，嘿，你肚子里有书吗？我说，是的，好吧，读读这一章。他读了一章。他说，再给我两章。好吧。再写两章。想知道我在范奈斯机场的飞机失事，机组人员把我抛弃在飞机上
and Barry Sonnenfeld called your mother that episode. And I give him these three chapters and we go out to six publishers and all six say yes as long as you write it cause you know, I have a specific tone and I have lots of a side and I loved it. I would write 40 pages a day. I cut out 40% of the book just cause I like short movies and short books, but it was a piece of cake cause I'm writing about myself. I'm Jewish and an only child.
以及巴里·宋菲尔德叫你妈妈那一集。我给了他这三章，我们去找了六家出版商，只要你写，他们都说是，因为你知道，我有特定的语调，我有很多旁白，我喜欢它。我每天写40页。我删掉了书中40%的内容，因为我喜欢短电影和短书，但这很容易，因为我在写我自己。我是犹太人，还是独生子。
What could be better? So I, I loved it. And then we went out with it and it got a great review in the times and the Wall Street Journal and then COVID struck and you know, Amazon saying we will ship this book in the next 18 weeks. So that was really depressing. So, so, so Barry now, listen, you mentioned, you mentioned Telluride. You used to live on the East, you were, you know, you grew up in New York and then you,
还有什么比这更好的？所以我，我很喜欢它。然后我们把它发布了，它在《泰晤士报》和《华尔街日报》上得到了很好的评论，然后新冠疫情爆发了，你知道，亚马逊说我们将在未来18周内发货这本书。所以这真的很令人沮丧。所以，所以，所以巴里现在，听着，你提到了，你提到了特柳赖德。你过去住在东部，你，你知道，你在纽约长大，然后你，
you lived in Long Island for many years and then you lived in Telluride and now you live in Pemberton, British Columbia. It's about a half hour north of Whistler and I just couldn't, well, here's the thing. So we're shooting a series of unfortunate events and it's a close set and there's this woman who's kind of sporty and, and her son and I'm joking around with her and making fun of her and she's making fun of me. This is October 2016 and I say, who are you and why are you here? Cause I'm goofing around with her and she says, oh hi, I'm Chrissy Clark.
你在长岛住了很多年，然后你住在特柳赖德，现在你住在不列颠哥伦比亚省的彭伯顿。它在惠斯勒以北大约半小时路程，我只是不能，好吧，事情是这样的。所以我们正在拍摄《雷蒙·斯尼奇的不幸历险》，这是一个封闭的片场，有一个女人，她有点运动型，还有她的儿子，我在和她开玩笑，取笑她，她也在取笑我。这是2016年10月，我说，你是谁，你为什么在这里？因为我在和她胡闹，她说，哦嗨，我是克里斯蒂·克拉克。
I'm the premier of British Columbia and I say to her, you may be very important to me in one week. And the night of the election in 2016, she emailed me and said, are you ready? And I'm one of those guys who actually said yes. And sweetie and I have moved to Canada. Wow. Yeah. Wow.
我是不列颠哥伦比亚省的省长，我对她说，你可能在一周后对我非常重要。2016年选举之夜，她给我发邮件说，你准备好了吗？我是那种真正说了“是”的人。我和斯威蒂搬到了加拿大。哇。是的。哇。
And I've seen, you show, you sent me some pictures over the last couple of years. Your place looks incredible and you love living in Canada and you love Canadians. Well, we, we had a pretty spectacular place in Telluride. We had 62 acres and views all the way to Utah, but we were living at 10,000 feet and we were just getting too old for that altitude. I'm really old. You do, you need, you need supplemental oxygen there. It's not, not uncommon.
我见过，你，你过去几年给我发了一些照片。你的地方看起来不可思议，你喜欢住在加拿大，你喜欢加拿大人。嗯，我们在特柳赖德有一个相当壮观的地方。我们有62英亩的土地，可以看到一直到犹他州的景色，但我们住在10000英尺高的地方，我们对那个海拔来说太老了。我真的很老了。你确实，你确实需要那里的补充氧气。这并不，并不罕见。
Yeah. You know, I thought we would be a good idea to pressurize our house and then I realized the first time someone opened the window, they'd be sucked out into the, so I thought, maybe that's a bad idea. Okay. One other question for Jason. Yes, sir. Did you win the Toyota Grand Prix or, I did, yeah, yeah.
是的。你知道，我以为我们会是一个好主意给我们的房子加压，然后我意识到第一次有人打开窗户，他们就会被吸进，所以我以为，也许那是个坏主意。好吧。给杰森的另一个问题。是的，先生。你赢得了丰田大奖赛吗？我赢了，是的，是的。
I attended that race almost every year. I know Brolin was part of that at one point, Mark Consuelos. I became good friends with Bobby Ray Hall. Oh, wow. Really? Through Letterman. Yeah. In fact, Ray Hall, I sent Ray Hall my low to super seven and he reboarded the engine
我几乎每年都参加那场比赛。我知道布洛林曾经是其中的一部分，马克·康苏洛斯。我和鲍比·雷·霍尔成了好朋友。哦，哇。真的吗？通过莱特曼。是的。事实上，雷·霍尔，我把我的路特斯Super 7寄给了雷·霍尔，他重新装配了引擎
out for me and all that. So. Oh my God. Yeah. Do you still race at all? No, I, I, I'd left that, no, but that was so much, so much fun. I did that. I did it a few times.
为我，诸如此类。所以。哦，我的天哪。是的。你还赛车吗？不，我，我，我离开了那个，不，但那太，太有趣了。我做了那个。我做了几次。
I really, really enjoyed it. You don't still, do they still have that race? I want to say they do. I think they might. I mean, I'm not down there anymore, but I would always stand at the corner where I knew Mario Andretti would go into the tires because it was always fun watching Mario never finish a race. Let me tell you something.
我真的，真的很喜欢它。你不再，他们还有那场比赛吗？我想说他们有。我想他们可能有。我是说，我不在那里了，但我总是站在我知道马里奥·安德雷蒂会冲进轮胎的角落，因为看着马里奥从不完成比赛总是很有趣。让我告诉你一件事。
I don't know anything about the long, the long beach race, but I do know that if there was a race, any kind of car, a stock car or whatever, and it was from Sean's house to Chin Chin in West Hollywood, I tell you, he would win. He would win every time. The best part is that it's a hundred percent. Barry, we've taken up way too much of your time and you've been way too generous with us and you're such a great guy and I just love you and I miss you and thank you for coming to do this show and just wish you all the best up in Canada.
我对长滩比赛一无所知，但我确实知道，如果有一场比赛，任何种类的车，库存车什么的，是从肖恩家到西好莱坞的Chin Chin，我告诉你，他会赢。他每次都会赢。最棒的部分是它是百分之百的。巴里，我们占用了你太多的时间，你对我们太慷慨了，你是一个这么好的人，我爱你，我想念你，谢谢你来做这个节目，祝你在加拿大一切顺利。
I hope we see you soon. I'd love to work with you guys anytime. You're all so, so talented. That really would be a dream. They say don't meet your heroes, but watching you on, you know, doing your interviews, I was hoping that you would be as charming and as friendly and as entertaining as you are there and now in person, you really are. So thank you for spending some time with us.
希望我们很快见到你。我很乐意随时和你们一起工作。你们都那么，那么有才华。那真的会是一个梦想。他们说不要见你的英雄，但看着你，你知道，做你的采访，我希望你会像你在那里一样迷人，友好和有趣，现在亲自见面，你确实是。所以谢谢你花时间和我们在一起。
Loved every second of it, guys. Thank you so much. Thanks, Barry. Thanks, Barry. Bye, Barry. Bye. Bye. Bye.
喜欢每一秒，伙计们。非常感谢。谢谢，巴里。谢谢，巴里。再见，巴里。再见。再见。再见。
Oh, Will. Will, you got a nice streak going here with your guests. I mean, he's... I know. Super fun. He's a real hero of mine. Barry's one of those guys. I just...
哦，威尔。威尔，你和你的客人们在这里有一个很好的连胜。我是说，他是……我知道。超级有趣。他是我真正的英雄。巴里是那种人。我只是……
What a thrill. I got to know him because we worked together. We did RV and then I did a couple of days on that. I did one day on Men in Black 3. I was going to say, we said, don't put too funny people together and then I was thinking about the fact that I did this scene with Will Smith and I was like, well, I guess I was the under... Who was the straight man in that scene?
多么激动。我认识他是因为我们一起工作。我们做了《房车之旅》，然后我在那上面做了几天。我在《黑衣人3》上做了一天。我正想说，我们说，不要把两个搞笑的人放在一起，然后我在想我拍了那个和威尔·史密斯的场景，我想，好吧，我想我是那个……那个场景里的捧哏是谁？
I guess it was me. I guess it was me. Yeah. Revealed here. I didn't know all the other stuff that he did until you said... I didn't know he did. Oh, no. When Harry met Sally?
我想是我。我想是我。是的。在这里揭晓。我不知道他做的所有其他事情，直到你说……我不知道他做了。哦，不。《当哈利遇到莎莉》？
This guy. He shot. And he's established a lot of what are now kind of tried and true... Easy. I didn't know that. ...aesthetics. It was so nice to meet him. And yeah, I always loved him on Letterman.
这家伙。他拍了。而且他建立了很多现在被称为那种久经考验的……容易。我不知道。……美学。见到他真是太好了。是的，我一直很喜欢他在莱特曼节目上的表现。
He was so funny. Yeah. That would be so fun to be on set with him. And I'd have to just turn into soldier mode, right? Because you don't want to be that dick that like says, well, yeah, I don't think if you're going to do a Barry Sonnenfeld project, you sign on for that and service what he's doing because it's so beautifully specific. Yeah.
他太搞笑了。是的。和他在片场一起会很有趣。我必须进入士兵模式，对吧？因为你不想成为那个混蛋，说，好吧，是的，我不认为如果你要拍一个巴里·宋菲尔德的项目，你签下那个并服务于他正在做的事情，因为它非常漂亮地具体。是的。
And he just goes faster, faster, flatter, faster, flatter. Just faster. I love that. And he does. He just wants you to kind of get it out and really trust the material. And so you've got to kind of... You know, he's done so many things that were great men in black, obviously, and get shorty. All those things were just...
他只是走得更快，更快，更平，更快，更平。只是更快。我喜欢那个。他确实。他只是想让你把它拿出来，真正信任材料。所以你必须有点……你知道，他做了很多伟大的事情，《黑衣人》，显然，还有《矮子当道》。所有这些事情都只是……
You know, he was able to rely on those great scripts that he believed in and shot them. And I don't know, man. He's a... Anyway, great guy. And so interesting too, right? Such an interesting life he's led. Yeah. Fascinating.
你知道，他能够依靠那些他相信的伟大剧本并拍摄它们。我不知道，伙计。他是一个……总之，伟大的人。而且也很有趣，对吧？他过着如此有趣的生活。是的。迷人。
And I can't wait for the book. I know. You don't read. I know. I was just trying to say something nice about his book. When's the last book you read? I'm reading right now these old books that I read when I was like in junior high. These like mystery books.
我等不及那本书了。我知道。你不读。我知道。我只是想说一些关于他书的好话。你上次读的书是什么时候？我现在正在读这些我初中时读过的旧书。这些像神秘书一样。
Are we talking about like choose your own adventure books, maybe? What are the hardy boys doing now? Yeah. No. Hey, did you guys ever see that movie House with a Clock in its Walls a few years ago? I did not, but I know of it. Yeah. So that whole series, I was such a fan of as a kid, so I'm re-reading them.
我们在谈论像选择你自己的冒险书吗，也许？哈迪男孩现在在做什么？是的。不。嘿，你们看过几年前那部电影《墙上有一个钟的房子》吗？我没有，但我知道它。是的。所以整个系列，我小时候是那么大的粉丝，所以我正在重读它们。
Okay. So you're just re-reading. You don't want to just start to read some new books? No. Nothing that's going to further my brain. I just want to go back. Yeah, right. Yeah.
好吧。所以你只是在重读。你不想只是开始读一些新书吗？不。没有什么能促进我的大脑。我只是想回去。是的，对吧。是的。
What about you, Will? You're still combing through World War II history? No, I've been reading this book about this guy who's a, it's actually a detective novel set in that era. It's pretty fascinating stuff, but it's like historical fiction. And just when you read, you're not sitting down at 4 p.m. in the middle of the afternoon and reading books. Sometimes, yeah.
你呢，威尔？你还在梳理二战历史吗？不，我一直在读这本书，关于这个家伙，他是一个，它实际上是一部设定在那个时代的侦探小说。这是相当迷人的东西，但它就像历史小说。当你读的时候，你不是在下午4点坐在下午中间读书。有时，是的。
I mean, it's the only thing, it just puts you to bed, right? It's like the last half hour of every day. That's my thing. Like reading just that jacket title would put me to sleep. Yeah. Well, I read it, I read it at night. Like I do, that is my sort of my one thing, my one sort of luxury that I allow. Sometimes I'll be, you know, I'll get into bed and I'll be like, you know what, I'm
我是说，这是唯一的事情，它只是让你上床睡觉，对吧？就像每天的最后半小时。那是我的事。就像读那个夹克标题会让我睡着。是的。好吧，我读它，我晚上读它。就像我做的那样，那是我的一种东西，我允许的一种奢侈。有时我会，你知道，我会上床，我会像，你知道吗，我
just going to read for an extra half hour tonight. I'm like, I'm just being so naughty. Let me ask you a question. When you're sharing a bed with someone, do you read before you go for the nookie or is it, or do you read after? As like a treat. The nookie. Oh, go for the nookie.
只是今晚要多读半小时。我就像，我只是太淘气了。让我问你一个问题。当你和某人共用一张床时，你是先读完再去搞那个，还是，或者你读完之后？作为一种享受。那个。哦，去搞那个。
Okay, Boomer, I don't know, listen, man, stop making it sound so sexy. Yeah. I'm going to sit there with your book with your bifocals on and hope that she notices this hot dude. Hey, I don't, I don't pencil in my sexual engagements, like it's going to be at 9 0 5 and I'm going to do that and get my nookie in it. Or is it like a foreplay thing, like watch me read and see how hot I am as I read my book.
好吧，婴儿潮一代，我不知道，听着，伙计，别让它听起来那么性感。是的。我要坐在那里，戴着双光眼镜读你的书，希望她注意到这个火辣的家伙。嘿，我没有，我没有把我的性行为写在日程表上，就像它会在9点05分，我会做那个并搞定它。或者这就像一种前戏，就像看着我读，看看我读我的书时有多火辣。
Listen, I'm just like, no, I just do it any time, like I'll just be like, you know, whenever. Well, listen, he was, thank you for bringing him on. I was wanting to meet him. So that was cool. Yeah. I'm sure maybe, maybe the three of us can do, can do a little project with him and make it funny. He would be so funny and he's such a great engaging guy.
听着，我只是像，不，我只是随时做，就像我会像，你知道，无论什么时候。好吧，听着，他是，谢谢你带他来。我一直想见他。所以那很酷。是的。我相信也许，也许我们三个可以和他做一个小项目，让它变得有趣。他会非常有趣，他是一个非常伟大、迷人的人。
I'll get emails from him at the weirdest times where he'll be like, I just heard a Reese's commercial after GMC, the last GMC, it doesn't really sound like you. What were you doing that day? And I'm like, I don't know. And an email. So then I have to email him like, I don't know, man, what's wrong with it? How do you end your emails? Yours truly.
我会收到他发来的邮件，在最奇怪的时候，他会说，我刚刚在GMC之后听到了一个里斯的广告，最后一个GMC，听起来不太像你。你那天在做什么？我就像，我不知道。一封邮件。所以我必须给他发邮件，像，我不知道，伙计，它有什么问题？你如何结束你的邮件？你真诚的。
I love you forever. Oh, yeah, no, here comes Sean, he's teasing himself up. Yours truly. And then you say something like, bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye.
我永远爱你。哦，是的，不，肖恩来了，他在逗自己。你真诚的。然后你说点什么，像，再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。
Bye. Bye. Bye. Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。再见。我们的下一集将在一个星期后发布，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你现在可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅Apple Podcasts或Wondry应用程序中的Wondry Plus提前且无广告收听。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。